so how do we build this thing which of
these do you think is the simplest table
out of 1 2 3 4 which do you think is the
simplest they start I think 3 I agree
because you think about what kinds of
things do we know about the item so I'm
starting to build my schema right so at
the top have the name what things do I
know about items come back to your table
here will I know it has a unique number
right I'm going after that first because
that's going to be my primary key so
you've got to know and I'm gonna call
that primary key but I also know what
else do I know about it
okay that's it that's it now some of you
thought I need to put more information
here right because I know I think I know
other stuff about items right for
instance I know stuff about like when
it's borrowed and who's got it okay but
can you see why these things do not
really belong to items right because
these things change for item to item
right so these really belong to the loan
that's why they're in the most hey rule
in the first place okay
so when you're building the anything
that's it . this is all the data I need
okay finished okay now there's going to
be some relationships right where do you
think this would be linked to you have a
look at all the other tables you've got
which do you think is the most logical
connection lawyers anyone want to go for
anything else who thinks like heads are
straight okay Raymond why
say it again
yeah good okay so by the way it and I
just wanted to make you second-guess
yourself because you know I don't want
you to say yes this is the right one
mister who said so okay I want you to
know like yes
for this reason exactly right when you
think about items and loads okay it's an
item that's going to be loaned right
whereas an item only gets to an employee
or to a department through a loan does
that make sense
so my next table over okay right now
what kinds of things do I know about the
loan what would you put is the very
first thing you can say okay I could get
I don't know but right because you can
see that's that's kind of like when you
look at this table right that's probably
the most when it jumps out that's the
most useful thing for soybeans okay but
turns out even though I will put item
number into this table okay it's not
that useful
it's like useful enough it's useful but
it's not useful enough okay can anyone
see the problem why shouldn't I know me
the first thing I think of yeah cuz when
I go there right I'm gonna have look
just here right early in this limited
set of data I've gone six six three four
coming up twice because it's been
borrowed twice and I assume as time
progresses it's gonna get borrowed one
times okay so item number will not do as
a primary key for this table which makes
sense because it's a primary key for
another table so I need to each reducer
Kate right there is nothing in this
table nothing in this table which is
sufficient to be a primary key can you
see that right so it's not very well
desired in that way so let's introduce
one what do you think we should call it
loan ID load number whatever that's my
primary key okay I need to put that in
next I'm gonna put in my item Obama and
now here's the great thing right because
we've introduced because we've
introduced in items table I don't need
to say item name again because once you
know that number you know the name from
a different table
okay right what else do we put date okay
now there's two dates out there there's
a there's a bar na when it went out and
there's a return date okay so I need
both
I think that's what they're cool yeah
okay what do you think am I finished
setting up okay now now I've got some
choices here right thinking back I'm
going to have right and the lowest table
employees table either table department
table so when I think that okay where
has this item gone right I can choose
either employees or department now which
one is a better option
yeah
okay yeah okay now that's true that's
true you've got this department which is
sort of the it's sort of what's the
world we can talk it's the agent that's
actually making the body happen partly
because the departments have to assume
by them okay I'm gonna suggest though
probably in this question especially
because there's on behalf of employees
right and also that in this table below
right you can see that the only thing it
sees an example yeah here we go in
menswear for instance okay these two
items get both bored by the same
department okay
but the table itself distinguishes
between the different people that it's
have actually within that department
I've got the item okay now can anyone
give me maybe a practical reason why it
might be helpful to have the employee as
a person who's grabbed the arm the item
had that listed there rather than the
entire department and it won't give me a
practice
sorry I mean if the department is if the
whole departments got it and that's all
I need to know isn't that sufficient
yeah bingo I can't put yourself in the
position of the inventory keeper right
and you're like where's my laptop okay
you got to go hunt it down right if a
department how many employees is a
department hat tonight right it could be
five it could be ten it could be 50
right I don't wanna have to search
through 50 people about the awkward I
think I wanna be able to go straight to
them
right probably the supervisor ID might
be important in case that person thought
around this will be that go to your
person but I reckon employees for the
best option there okay even though you
could probably go either way that's not
a critical error by the way if you put
the supervisor here
sorry department here okay you're still
getting the general idea you still have
the destination for where this item is
going okay but probably employees a more
specific kind of person now are we done
what do we got to put onto this table a
couple of things servicing
okay first is there's a relationship
right we said we went from items to
loads because there was a relationship
so when I got this sort of filled out
I've got item number so I don't know
about right so when you draw this line
this becomes a foreign key yes
now question what kind of relationship
is this you can be one-to-one
one-to-many or many to many what kind is
it
one too many who thinks once a minute
two people three people four people
three and a half people not sure okay
hands now alright um if you don't think
you want too many who thinks it's
one-to-one though when things is what
one okay that's fine it's not who thinks
it's very too many I guess if you didn't
raise your hand you're confused yes okay
that's fine that's all right um it's
what to me what so many is right now the
question is why
how can I know it's one to me what's the
way that I test whether something is
one-to-one like how do I know I can't
say let's say that again pop slowly say
okay good so let's think about it I'll
I'll phrase it another way right um how
many items right I'll load in a single
bone you're just gonna have one of them
right each load just once okay but how
many times can an item get load many
many different times as you can see here
right it just gets reload and relearn to
reload okay
so that's why you're gonna put where's
my one to me isn't it small sorry but
there's a 1 here and a mini here what
item gets more many times
okay does that make sense okay now
always done with this table there's
something that needs to be changed as a
as a field that has a problem can anyone
see it yeah yeah that's right employee
it's kind of bogus name for a field
right in fact it's the name of the table
so what should the field be called right
now that also plays every time you see
like number or ID more or less that's
always gonna be a key of some kind is a
primary key is it a primary key door
it's pretty got one right it's the key
for some other table right so it's a
foreign key and that tells you the next
thing that you're gonna go to
okay so I'm running out of space here
but you can probably just go across your
page I'm gonna draw this down and it's
going to go somewhere else
okay so my next table is if it's the
employee yeah I'm following yes I'm
going to the employee table
high-five [ __ ] yeah well that's okay I'm
awake I'm awake right we already noticed
primary key will be it's the employee ID
and in fact the rest of this song the
rest of this table was really easy to
build right because they told you what
did it right the employee table includes
blah blah blah blah okay
so let's fill that out I've got max
which is the primary key I've got the
first name and the last thing note by
the way I mentioned this when I did the
review for the last exam as well but
these are all up there no spaces or
anything like that that's why the
capital letters they do the near
different words okay is that it is that
the employee table I mean that's that's
all it says in the question that I need
right the employee table includes those
attributes okay yeah yeah good so we
already know that I'm gonna have to have
extra fields in here to connect this to
my fourth and final table right and we
picked departments okay so if I have
departments over here
sorry that's a deed I'm gonna have to
have a department ID it here so you can
use DEP tears
abbreviation her and obviously because
it's an ID again it'll be a key but not
the key in this table key of another one
right okay now I think that's probably
not the employee table because these
ones are mandated and this one is
implied okay so okay now what kind of
relationship do I have here from loans
to employees loans to employers again
it's what we won so many is violence the
most common one okay
now which one's one which one's me okay
on the employees table that is what
employee can borrow lots of different
things I assume okay but every single
load alone is not to multiple different
people okay so alone has just one
employee attachment okay I'm almost
finished
we're almost there right the department
table what do we got well obviously I
have to have a department ID that's
going to be my primary key
what else ok good so I need the
supervisor this is where they come in
since I don't have a whole table devoted
to them ok so I don't need to call that
a foreign key because I don't have
another table that is going to refer to
anything else
yeah good yes just to UM increase the
increase the efficiency of this and make
things smaller okay
so instead of writing ladieswear
momentum though which is quite a long
thing right I think you could just call
it L M or MW what about okay and then
the full name you can have it separately
then you can adjust it as maybe there's
your table okay and here's our
relationship here what kind of
relationship is it once a mini again
right which way which way good four
months okay
now where do we have troubles if you had
to supervise a table you immediately had
some troubles okay because the way you
raised your fields for that table would
have been very confusing if you missed
out some data especially data that was
actually mended in the question you're
lost look if you up if you didn't do
this if you didn't get all the
relationships in the right order that
was problematic because that's that's
crucial that's understanding the way
that objects relate to each other all
right and then apart from that so long
as it was laid out in a logical way some
people had their relationships like all
overlapping like a terrible spider's web
and eventually I read it but it's just
don't do that to people okay